alisha connaît désormais la rythmique
parker depuis le début de la pandémie
ce ballet incessant de brancards ne
faiblit pas manager d'un funérarium dans
le quartier d'harlem à new york
alisha essaye de ne refuser personne
quitte à se retrouver débordés
ce jour là ce sont de nouveaux corps qu
elle réceptionne de personnes décédées
des suites du coc vite 19
c'est dur pour moi de ne pas pouvoir
être au service des familles comme
j'aimerais l'être le plus dur c'est de
devoir refuser des gens donc j'essaye de
ne pas le faire et c'est pour ça qu'on
est si débordés
de nombreuses personnes sont mortes du
kobus bien sûr et donc les familles sont
en quarantaine et ne viennent pas aux
enterrements
alors il n'ya que nous l'employé des
pompes funèbres et la personne décédée
au cimetière donc on filme l'inhumation
et en envoie la vidéo à la famille et
c'est dur les choses ont totalement
changé
si le nombre de décès journaliers du
coronavirus a été divisé par plus de
deux par rapport au pic de 799 morts
enregistré le 9 avril dernier à new york
les pompes funèbres de la ville sont
sous tension et les employés sont
souvent témoins de scènes traumatisantes
il y a écrit qu'ovide qu'ovide 19 sur
les sacs mortuaires et ils sont empilés
sur des étagères dans certaines remorque
les corps sont à même le sol
il ya même certains employés certains
soignants qui ne veulent pas y mettre
les pieds
alors ils nous disent à nous les
employés des pompes funèbres d'y aller
pour trouver la personne décédée qu'on
doit prendre en charge et corps j'entre
il y a une mère de corps par terre et je
fais tout pour ne marchez sur personne
c'est traumatisant la moitié des
demandes que reçoit ce funérarium
concernent des victimes du coronavirus
ali shah et ses employés sont obligés de
travailler près de 80 heures par semaine
contre 40
habituellement et ce 7 jours sur 7 les
gens sont désespérés ils nous disent ils
vont envoyer cette personne qui m'est
proche la fosse commune l'hôpital ne
peut plus la garde et est ce que vous
pouvez m'aider et c'est si dur de leur
dire de rappeler dans deux jours ça me
brise le coeur
comme on peut le voir sur l'ordinateur
il ya tout un tas d'appels qu'on doit
encore traiter en va à brooklyn on va
dans le queens sauve à manhattan en va
dans le new-jersey on court partout pour
aller chercher les corps des personnes
décédées et notre sous-sol déborde on a
des boîtes en carton pour les crémations
direct empilées les unes sur les autres
c'est dur une scène douloureuse que cet
employé ne préfère pas montré à l'heure
actuelle la pandémie de corona virus a
causé à new york la mort de dix sept
mille personnes soit un habitant sur
cinq cents